this is the big lie that you have spoken
out against for a long time you should
feel very vindicated over the pass well
it's pretty vindicated lately because
the the big lie we've always heard is oh
these college campuses these are just a
bunch of idiots just wait until they get
out into the real yeah yeah well I'm
looking around the real world now and
I'm seeing the consequences of those
college campuses as the buildings are
burning down all around the country all
the people over the last you know five
years were yelling at guys like us for
talking about what was going on on
college campuses oh it's just a bunch of
kids yeah you know and it's like
actually you do know that this is
leaking out into society and these
people are graduating and they're
starting to take down institutions
literally but you have young editors at
publishing houses that are getting books
cancelled at the New York Times and the
New York Times has been taken out do you
think this thing is going to destroy
virtually every liberal institution what
we have this is the big lie that you
have spoken out against for a long time
you should feel very vindicated over the
past you know it's pretty vindicated
lately because the big lie we've always
heard is oh these college campuses these
are just a bunch of idiots just wait
until they get out into the real yeah
yeah well I'm looking around the real
world now and I'm seeing the
consequences of those college campuses
as the buildings are burning down all
around the country yeah
the issue with the institution's you
bring up is an interesting one because
we've been told for the past few weeks
that all of these protests are about
institutional racism right but then it
occurred to me the left controls every
major institution in America yeah
control the media controls higher
education and lower education controls
Hollywood controls big tech controls
administrative government control
basically other than talk radio and some
little parts of the internet the left
controls every institution so if there's
institutional racism whose fault is that
well not only whose fault is it but they
are the ones putting it into the
institutions they're the ones making its
systemic Harvard yeah Harvard says we
want less Asian people because you guys
had it too good through hard work and
education so we're going to institute a
racist policy I don't know if you saw it
I just tweeted last night or this
morning this thing in Tacoma Washington
we're there now go it is going to be in
practice that if you have lost your job
or need housing because of Co vid
they're only going to help people who
identify as people of color well that
makes it easy might have something I
might you know the Sicilian wiggle room
here yeah right I mean you see that you
saw this with ubereats right yeah love
this one they come out they say if
you're ordering from a black-owned
business whatever that I don't I mean
are you gonna measure the equity here a
black on to business there's no delivery
fees but if it's a white owned business
there will be no they are the ones
actually injecting racism into the
system of course but but that's the
point you know I it occurred to me I
thought a friend came up to me the other
day said Michael it's almost like they
want us to be racists there the
mainstream media the left they're
ginning up this racial division it's
like they want us to be racist and I
realize they do they actually need you
to be racist because so much of
liberalism is about overcoming this
oppressive past right so the whole story
of liberalism is yeah you can't end it
can't end it's gut you've always got to
be freeing yourself but look around you
remember early on in the riots the
mainstream media tried to blame white
supremacists how many Klansmen are there
in America like for left or something I
don't I didn't see a whole lot of white
hoods out there I saw I saw a white hood
on the governor of Virginia the Democrat
Ralph Northam I didn't see it in the
riots so they they have to either create
this boogeyman or actually try to create
racists
if only to have a villain to then
overcome well so when they're going
through these cities destroying
everything we were talking about West
Hollywood which is literally the gayest
place on earth they have rainbow
crosswalks the entire West Hollywood
right now as we tape this is board it up
I used to live there I went there a
couple days ago it is boarded up it
looks like a third-world nation right
and on every sign outside it says BLM
the implication being don't destroy our
business will for you black lives
matters but help watch what I can do
here if it was white supremacist
so that we're rampaging through the
neighborhood wouldn't you be writing
like white power yeah yeah because then
you go oh I'm a white supremacist you're
a white supremacist don't don't bust up
my business of course and also it's
worth noting this is Pride Month right
so I think oh no we're not an expert I
thought this was supposed to be the
month to celebrate West Hollywood and
the LGBTQ community but that I don't if
progressivism changes so fast that now
Pride Month is canceled and now Pride
Month is BLM month what's it gonna be
next year you remember a couple years
ago at Toronto pride when they stopped
BLM stopped the March and said you guys
can't March any further unless you sign
our edict or our whatever it is and and
basically they did and they let the
March and a bunch of us talked about it
and I said oh here you go again here you
guys go again this this issue of the the
intersectional politics it's it's an
interesting one here because you're
almost seeing the return of more of an
old-school Marxism you know for the past
10 years you've been hearing about how
the gay community has something in
common with the trans community just
kind of ironic because those two
communities sort of contradict one
another either their there are
individual sexes and same-sex attraction
is having to do with the two sexes yeah
or there's no such thing as sexes and so
that contradicts the the GE and the LGBT
right but those have something to do
together you can have Gloria Steinem
radical feminists holding hands with
Linda Sarsour and Islamist yeah at the
women's March that makes sense but now
you're seeing that I think begin to fade
away a little bit into more of an
old-school
the black lives matter interest is not
the LGBT interest and the BLM one is
going to take precedence even though all
of all of it comes down to a sort of
radical Marxism and this this is the
part that I think some of the squishy
types don't get because they'll say the
word black lives matter nobody disagrees
with that here's my evidence that nobody
disagrees with that everybody posted the
black square on social media everybody
everybody in government in media in the
corporate America in all your friends
they all did it it's no one disagrees
with that state yeah even people that
didn't want to do it not because they're
not for black live yeah but because they
don't like being bullied into things
they
did it do they did it but then you look
at the black lives matter website the
about us section and it's not just about
black lives mattering at one point it
says we exist to destroy the quote
Western proscribed nuclear family what
what does that have to do with police
brutality or it's obviously and you can
see the founders of BLM come from
radical leftist organizations which get
their funding from the open societies
foundation which is run by George Soros
that's that's not a conspiracy theory
with no it's not I don't even know how
would it be George Soros has lived his
life to basically fund every young Jew
hating thing there is pretty much right
right he would love to have Israel wiped
off of the map so the idea that saying
that George Soros funds these things
yeah is anti-semitic is completely right
it'd be it becomes what what the left
wants to pretend is that this is a
racial issue primarily and it's not the
lefty uses race all the time but it's
not you can see when you look at the
about us section of the BLM page when
you look at who's funding it it's
primarily ideological and I think
there's some squishy conservatives and
Republicans who want to go along with it
because they're afraid of being called
racist even when they're not at all
racist but that's a that's a very bad
deal to get into because then you're
accepting radical leftist premises that
are gonna undercut everything you stand
for in many ways though do you think the
ship has sailed to the point that we
don't have enough power yeah it's this
thing that that you're still a an out
sense and and thoughtful analysis and
people are waking up to it and I do
think a ton of red people are being read
pilled right now because because just
reality is red filling them right I've
got Hollywood lefties friends that are
calling me in there like where do you
get a gun so it's like so something's
happening here but in many ways do you
think that the destructive force of this
thing has has so infiltrated everything
that nothing can can return you you've
hit the nail on the head which is we're
beginning to see more people than just
conservatives or classical liberals or
just normal people are seeing
yikes something has gone serious
along here and yet very little is being
done to stop it you see even the
President of the United States more or
less all he can do is tweet about it and
people are saying okay enough tweeting
you got actually do something but it
gets back to the institution's issue the
left controls the institution's which
means the left controls the levers of
power the only institution that we've
got on the right is talking and so we
can talk until we're blue in the face we
can point out hypocrisy until we're blue
in the face and the left says yeah okay
you've pointed out my hypocrisy I still
have the levers of power I think what is
required now the right and of
conservatives is to take back it actual
institutions of power and perhaps even
more importantly to be willing to
exercise that political power when we
have the ability meets the road what are
you saying like actually start separate
universities I mean there are some more
conservative leaning universities and
yeah some of them have thrived in the
midst of all this and University of
Chicago though it's not it's not
conservative per se but they have
actually instituted like an actual
defense of free speech and it probably
won't burn as quickly as the rest of
these other places but what do you
actually mean by that like what what
does institution-building look like so
that would be a wonderful thing I mean
unfortunately I could probably count the
conservative universities on one hand
and yeah but and they're really great
universities I guess the the silver
lining in the storm cloud of the
coronavirus lockdown and some of the
riots is that you're seeing a collapse
in many ways of this decrepit
educational infrastructure that that it
not only does not give people an
education and it does not give people an
ability to have a career and it does
saddle them with a lot of debt all it
does is indoctrinate them in a very
modern sort of politics which is not
worth the cost of admission if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell